[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous lecture i had mentioned
that although we were able to
formulate a theory for torsion
[Music]
for non-circular cross sections even
but we would still like to go for a kind
of theory
which would allow us to address various
problems
given a certain geometry instead of
guessing the solutions
and the way that we go about doing it is
to
use the uh what is what was actually
given by
ludwig prandtl which later came to be
known as the parental stress function
and please note that this is the same
parental proof gave us
the boundary layer theory all right so
uh as the name suggests it is a stress
function that will be
looking at and much in the same way that
the
airy stress function was presented with
the motivation
of satisfying the equilibrium equations
here also the motivation is somewhat
alike
so what we say is that
the stress components sigma xz and sigma
yz
they will be represented through these
expressions
twice g where g is the shear modulus
alpha is the same alpha that we had been
discussing
in the previous uh videos uh that is the
twist per unit length and the side that
we are looking at here
that is what is the stress function
sigma yz is equal to minus twice
g alpha del psi del x
and the underlying motivation for
considering these kinds of expressions
uh is to just ensure that
the third component that is a z
component of the
stress equilibrium equations that gets
satisfied
so del sigma xz
del x plus del
sigma yz del y
that should be equal to zero where we
note of course that sigma zz
uh is equal to zero
okay so given the you know given all the
kinematical hypothesis
uh that that we had already discussed in
the previous lectures
the sigma z will turn out to be equal to
zero uh
otherwise if this had not been zero then
we would have an extra term here
like plus del sigma z del z okay but we
don't have to worry about it now
okay so what happens is that if you
actually substitute this expression here
and this expression here
you'll see that this becomes a zero
equal to zero form so this is exactly
the same kind of things which we had
uh which we had seen in the case of the
arrest stress function also
but there uh we were our motivation was
to satisfy the
the x and y component of the stress
equilibrium equations
all right now that we have these two
expressions of sigma xz and sigma yz
what we would like to do is uh develop
some kind of relation
between these two expressions and what
we would uh what we had
from earlier meaning to say that if you
just go up
so we have these expressions for epsilon
y z and epsilon zx
all right so let me just copy these
so the epsilon yz and the epsilon zx
so this is our epsilon yz
and this is our epsilon zx
and please also note that uh
this kappa uh if
you just look back up
[Music]
so what we had said was that this kappa
this kappa here that is equal to alpha
phi
okay so we are going to use that
so
[Music]
that's it so
what we are going to end up with here is
that
sigma so i can make the change here
itself
[Music]
sigma y z uh okay maybe i'll not be
too much lazy i'll just write it again
sigma y z is going to be equal to
twice g epsilon y z
which means that i'll have g
alpha i'll take the alpha out of this
bracket
x plus del phi del y
and sigma zx or sigma xz
that is twice g epsilon zx
so i'll have g alpha
minus y plus del phi
del x okay
so all that i need to do is compare this
expression for the
sigma zx or sigma xz with this
expression
and this expression for sigma yz with
this
so
therefore
[Music]
i'll have minus twice
g alpha del
psi del x
from here will be equal to this thing
alpha g alpha
x plus del phi
del y so that
i actually end up with minus
twice del psi
del x is equal to
x plus del pi
del y and
from this one i'll have twice g
alpha del psi del y
that will be equal to this thing
that's g alpha
minus y plus del phi del x
so that's
twice del psi
del y is equal to
minus y plus del phi
del x okay so what i want to do
from here is
i want to eliminate the phi okay and the
way that i'll do it
is to take the del del x of this entire
equation
and from that subtract the del del y
of this equation the motivation uh here
of course
is to obtain a del square phi del x del
y here and to obtain del square phi del
x del y
here so that these two things will get
eliminated
okay so
so let me just take this terms to the
next page
so
[Music]
okay um me
adjust it a little bit so from these two
what i will obtain is
minus 2 dels square
psi del x square
minus 2 del square
psi del
y squared and when i take the del del x
of this
in that equation i'll get a 1 over here
and when i take the del del y
of this second equation i'll get a minus
1 over here so when i subtract these two
i will end up with a 2 so overall
i end up with minus
laplacian of psi
is equal to 1
or i can change that
del square psi is equal to minus 1
so that is the equation in terms of the
parental stress function
so let me box that it's a very important
equation
and it is kind of the counterpart of the
laplacian
of the phi equal to zero equation
which we had obtained earlier so what i
mean to say is that
this equation that we had obtained
earlier it is kind of the uh the
counterpart of that equation in terms of
the
bronte stress function okay so
next what about the boundary conditions
well we have the zero traction boundary
condition
uh on the outer surface of the shaft
okay so we use the
[Music]
the no traction
[Music]
boundary condition
on the outer surface of the shaft
[Music]
so what i mean to say here is that if i
just go back
to the this first diagram
this curved surface
covering the entire length of the shaft
that surface and
is entirely free of traction okay so on
that surface
i'll have the zero traction okay
so uh that will be given by sigma
xz nx
plus sigma yz
and y equal to 0
and in terms of the prandtl stress
function that is going to give me
r twice g alpha del psi
del y and let us not forget that this n
x
is nothing but d y d s
and this
sigma y z is minus twice g
alpha del psi del x
and this ny is minus
dx ds
so what we are going to obtain from here
is now we can just cancel out this twice
g
we can also get rid of the alpha so what
we are left with
is d psi d y
d y from here we remove this
get rid of this d s uh plus
this minus and this minus is plus and
uh this should be a partial derivative
sorry about that
[Music]
plus del psi del x
dx is equal to 0
[Music]
and that is nothing but
the differential of sine okay so
d psi where psi is a function of both x
and y that gets expanded out using the
chain rule as del psi del x dx plus del
si del y d
y so we have just gone the reverse way
and written this as the
differential of the sign okay and that
is equal to 0
what that implies is that
the side is a constant
on the periphery of the shaft
okay is a constant on the periphery of
the shaft so
on the entire cross section if you if
you just consider the cross section
again
on this index periphery this psi is a
constant
now if you had been wondering all along
that how
this using the prandtl stress function
actually helps us
in addressing problems given a certain
geometry
this is the missing link okay that
because
the psi will be a constant on the entire
periphery
so given a certain geometry all that we
need to know
is the equation which defines this
periphery and we can utilize
this uh this this condition that this
plantar stress function is a constant on
the periphery
to to obtain
an expression based on that geometry and
through the examples that we'll be doing
uh we'll see uh how that can be very
very
easily done okay so uh
another very important thing to note is
that uh
because this is a constant and because
the only connection that this psi has
with the stresses is through the
derivatives
then it really doesn't matter if you can
add or
subtract certain constants from this
okay
so we'll exploit those things later on
while
addressing the various examples uh but
for now what i want to do is
uh you see uh we are going kind of
uh neck to neck with the with the
theoretical framework which we had
developed in the previous
videos uh meaning to say that
we had obtained uh
a governing equation in terms of the
warping function phi
and here also we have obtained a
governing equation in terms of the
branded stress function
psi earlier we had obtained a governing
or a boundary condition in terms of the
of the warping function phi and here
also we have obtained
a kind of condition involving the
parental stress function
on the entire boundary but what is
missing however
is the connection with the torsional
rigidity which we have not talked about
okay so remember that earlier we had
obtained three conditions
or three uh three equations
so let me just go back and show you that
you see we had these three box uh
equations so what you would like to do
is to obtain um the counterpart of this
okay basically we want to have uh
an expression involving the torsional
rigidity
in terms of this partial stress function
okay so how do we do it
well
the torsional rigidity as i had
mentioned in the previous lecture
is given by this gj and if we just take
a look back
uh
this uh gj uh was like this
okay so uh
this was this uh basically i mean the g
is
simply the shear modulus the the only
thing involving
now the only thing that we need to note
here is this expression for the
for the chain so what i will do is i'll
just
just copy this thing
[Music]
[Music]
okay
so now uh what i would like to do is
simply replace the these expressions
involving the phi with those um
involving the psi
and for that all that i have to do is
just take a look back at the previous
page where i have this thing
uh the del phi del y can be expressed in
terms of the sign like this
it is minus 2 del psi del x minus x
so
that's it and for the del phi del x what
i have is
twice del psi del y plus y
all right
so if i just simplify that a little bit
uh let me not forget this this g
which is present on the left hand side
so i have this minus twice x del psi
del x minus x square
minus twice y del psi
del y minus y square
so this x squared cancels with this x
squared this y squared cancels with this
y squared
and what we are left with is this minus
twice g
x del psi del x
plus y del psi
del y so
as we have done so many times earlier we
are going to go forward
with the motivation of
using the the queen's theorem
and for that we'll just uh absorb this x
uh
within this partial derivative with
respect to x and this y with this within
this partial derivative with respect to
y
uh and let's see what we obtain
so del del x of x i
minus so this is basically
on del del x of x which is just 1 times
psi
plus del del y
of y psi
minus del del y of y
[Music]
times psi so that the del y of
y is just one
so we have this
and please note now that this uh this
particular combination del del x of
something plus del del y of something
is where we get to use the uh the
green's theorem
so that considering this term in this
term
uh what we are going to
end up with is x psi
and x plus y
psi and y
so this is cyclic integral over term
uh over the periphery and
for this whatever is left here that is
going to give us 4g
so we have a twice psi here minus twice
y that minus comes outside
that gives me the plus so 4g
psi d a
all right so uh it seems
a rather inconvenient looking expression
but we'll see later that this can be
further simplified
okay this can be significantly
simplified uh
but for now we'll just keep it uh as it
is um
here okay as we as we considered
the different situations uh especially
to do with singly connected domains
and simply connected domains and
multiple connected domains
will will carry out the simplifications
all right so now basically what we have
managed to do
is to obtain the the equations
corresponding
to the ones that we had obtained earlier
involving the warping function
but this time involving the parental
stress function and please note that
unlike the approach that we had been
doing in the various chapters earlier
and even in this chapter
we did not really proceed by any
variation in food
okay that's a major difference from
earlier
uh rather we we just took
um i mean it was it was more like an
exercise
in applied elasticity which we had done
in our previous semester
but no matter uh our objective has been
realized uh of obtaining the equations
the corresponding equations in terms of
the prandtl stress function
and as i have emphasized in the previous
page that
because we we are
[Music]
we have in our hand now the condition
that
the psi is a constant this very
important condition
that the psi is a constant of the
periphery it directly gives us a recipe
of connecting the given geometry to the
uh to the solution procedure all right
on that node
i'll end this video thank you very much